so i have two different xy relationships
being described here and what i would
like to do in this video is figure out
whether each of these relationships
whether they are either linear
relationships exponential relationships
or neither and like always pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
yourself
so let's look at this first relationship
right over here
and the key way to tell whether we're
dealing with a linear or exponential or
neither relationship is think about okay
for given change in x and you hear you
see each time here we are increasing x
by the same amount so we're increasing x
by three
so given that we are increasing x by a
constant amount by three each time
does y increase by a constant amount in
which case we would be dealing with a
linear relationship
or is there a constant ratio between
successive terms when you increase x by
a constant amount in which case we would
be dealing with an exponential
relationship so let's see here we're
going from negative two to five so we
are adding
seven when x increases by three y
increases by seven when x is increasing
by three y increases by seven again
when x increases by three y increases by
7 again
so here it is clearly a linear
relationship
linear
relationship in fact you can even
relationship
you could even plot this on a line if
you assume that these are samples on a
line you could think even about the
slope of that line for a change in x for
a given change in x the change in y is
always constant when our change in x is
3 our change in y is always 7. so this
is clearly a linear relationship
now let's look at this one
let's see looks like our x's are
changing by 1 each time so plus 1.
now what are y's changing by here it
changes by two
then it changes by
six all right it's clearly not linear
then it changes
by 18 clearly not a linear relationship
but this was linear this would be the
same amount same delta same change in y
for every time because we have the same
change in x
so let's test to see if it's exponential
if it's an exponential for each of these
constant changes in x's when we increase
x by 1 every time
our ratio of successive y should be the
same or another way to think about is
what are we multiplying y by so to go
from 1 to 3 you multiply
you multiply by 3. to go from 3 to 9 you
multiply by 3. to go from 9 to 27 you
multiply by 3.
so in a situation where every time you
increase x by a fixed amount in this
case 1
and the corresponding y's get multiplied
by some fixed amount then you are
dealing with an exponential relationship
exponential
exponential relationship right over here